We are putting a complete siege on Gaza.
No electricity...
no food, no water, no gas.
It's all closed.
We're fighting animals and are
acting accordingly.
That was the defense minister of Israel...
responding to the deadly attack
on October 7th by Hamas...
a militant group based in Gaza.
Hamas launched rockets,
killed over 1,400 civilians...
and kidnapped close to 200 people.
Within days, Israel bombarded
the Gaza Strip...
killing several thousand,
wiping out entire families...
and striking ambulances,
border crossings...
and residential buildings.
At the same time, Israel
told over 1 million civilians...
to leave their homes and move south.
Warning them of an escalation
of violence in the north.
But Israel is bombarding the south, too.
Leaving Palestinians trapped.
For as long as this conflict has existed...
movement in and out of the Gaza Strip...
has been, to one degree or another,
restricted.
The prime minister of the Israeli occupation,
Benjamin Netanyahu...
he knows very well
that people are not able to leave.
The Gaza Strip is the smaller of
the two Palestinian territories
occupied by Israel since 1967.
This sliver of land only 25 miles long
and 7.5 miles wide...
is home to over 2 million Palestinians.
Making it one of the most densely
populated areas in the world.
For the last 16 years
residents here have been living
under a harsh blockade...
that allows Israel to control
the flow of electricity, fuel
food, water, and medical supplies.
So they can dictate when
Palestinians receive essentials...
and when they're denied.
That control is rooted in
violence and destruction...
that goes back decades.
Before the establishment of Israel...
Gaza was part of what became known as
historic Palestine...
under Ottoman rule and later
under British occupation.
In 1947, as the British prepared to leave...
they left the fate of Palestine...
up to a newly formed United Nations...
who voted to divide Palestine
into a Jewish state...
and an Arab state.
Soon, Zionist forces and militias
began to forcibly expel
hundreds of thousands of Palestinians
from their land...
to establish the state of Israel.
Many internally displaced Palestinians
fled to this narrow stretch of land...
that would later become known as
the Gaza Strip.
So these refugees became
refugees because...
they were pushed out of their
towns and villages.
Some of them literally live
a mile away from
what used to be their
towns and villages.
Many others were forced to flee
to neighboring Arab countries.
Overwhelmed by refugees...
these countries immediately declared a war
against the new state of Israel
to support Palestinian Arabs.
They eventually lost to Israel...
but Jordan ended up occupying
the West Bank
and Egypt occupied Gaza City
and nearby towns
along these ceasefire lines.
Then in 1967...
another war broke out.
Amid Palestinian resistance
and fearing threats from neighboring
Arab countries...
Israel launched a full scale attack
on Jordan, Syria, and Egypt.
In just six days...
Israel captured the Gaza Strip
and the Sinai from Egypt...
the West Bank from Jordan and
the Golan Heights from Syria.
This was the beginning of
the Israeli occupation in Gaza...
that continues today.
Israel took control of all movement
from and to the Gaza Strip...
by land, air, and sea.
It placed troops along this line
and inside the Gaza Strip...
and allowed Palestinians to travel
between the Gaza Strip...
Israel, the West Bank,
and East Jerusalem.
But just a few months after the war
even though Palestinians now lived
under Israeli control...
they began to be referred to as
“non-citizens” or “foreign residents”
in official Israeli documents.
You inherit the status from
your parents and grandparents.
Being a stateless, unrecognized,
with no rights...
and you know this impacts your life.
This was also when Israel
started to build settlements
for Jewish Israelis inside of Gaza.
To Palestinians...
this meant even more land
being taken away from them.
And they were being closed in.
Israel did not allow Palestinians here
to operate their own seaport or airport.
Within the Gaza Strip...
Israel developed key industries
like agriculture...
to cater to Israeli and
West Bank markets...
taking advantage of Gaza's
cheap labor market
and paying Palestinians very little.
These economic challenges led to the rise
of a prominent Islamic social charity:
Mujama al-Islamiya.
At the time, this charity,
partially funded by Israel...
built schools, mosques, clinics
and provided more food
for Palestinians in Gaza.
But tensions simmered.
Israel feared a growing
resistance movement.
And in response, soldiers often frisked...
arrested and detained residents.
In 1987, that tension reached
a breaking point
after an Israeli truck crashed
into a civilian car...
killing four Palestinians.
Palestinians immediately responded
with protests, strikes, and boycotts
against occupation.
It would become known as
the first uprising...
or intifada.
And that same year
Mujama al-Islamiya transformed
into a militant group: Hamas.
Hamas was a group that came about
during the first Palestinian uprising.
And was not really a part
of institutional politics
for some time.
They weren't in charge of Gaza yet,
but they wanted to liberate
Palestinian territories from Israel's control...
and considered Israel
an illegitimate state.
After the first year of the intifada...
during which over 140 Palestinians
in Gaza were killed...
Hamas and other militant groups
began to attack Israelis more directly.
Then the intifada grew more violent in 1991...
which is also when Israel introduced
a permit system
that greatly restricted Gaza residents’
ability to work...
travel through Israel...
or access the West Bank
and East Jerusalem.
By the end of the First Intifada...
Israeli forces had killed over
1,000 Palestinians...
and Palestinian militants had killed
over 100 Israelis...
throughout Israel and
the occupied territories.
The uprising ended after the
internationally brokered
Oslo Peace Accords...
between Israel and the Palestine
Liberation Organization...
or the PLO.
This was a liberation movement
with an armed wing...
that fought for Palestinian rights
for decades.
The PLO agreed to disarm and recognize
Israel's right to exist.
But Hamas, which had very little
political support at the time
strongly opposed it.
The deal also created a new governing body:
The Palestinian Authority, or PA...
which allowed political parties
and elections in the Gaza Strip.
The PA was granted some autonomy
within small areas...
but Israel still controlled the territories
and the flow through these crossings.
The Oslo agreement
also promised Palestinians
some level of autonomy...
and a path to statehood in five years.
But that never happened.
Instead, what followed was
more Israeli settlements
on Palestinian land.
And a year later, following an attack
by an Israeli settler in the West Bank
and a series of bombings by
Palestinian militants
including Hamas...
Israel’s prime minister called for
the construction of a fence
around the Gaza Strip.
Gaza now had a physical barrier
between it
and the outside world.
These moves made Palestinians
trust the Israeli government and
peace negotiations even less...
and it would lead to a second uprising.
On September 28th, 2000
Israeli politician Ariel Sharon visited
Al-Aqsa mosque...
a muslim holy site in Jerusalem
that's largely inaccessible to Palestinians
in the Gaza Strip.
This visit sparked widespread protests
and violent clashes...
resulting in Israeli forces killing four
Palestinian children the next day.
And Palestinian militants carried out
suicide bombings.
Back in the Gaza Strip...
Palestinians broke down much of this barrier.
The Israeli government soon
built it back up
and heavily militarized it with more troops
and observation posts.
They further canceled travel
and work permits...
restricting movement through
this crossing even more....
and eventually destroyed Gaza's
only major airport...
and its under-construction seaport.
By the end of the Second Intifada in 2005...
Palestinian militants had
killed over 900 Israelis...
and Israeli forces killed over
3000 Palestinians.
The Second Intifada gradually
came to an end...
as Israel dismantled all Jewish Israeli
settlements in the Gaza Strip...
and withdrew the ground troops.
Then another internationally brokered
agreement gave the PA
control of this crossing with Egypt
on the Gaza side...
and allowed trucks and convoys
to flow between
the Gaza Strip and the West Bank.
But Israel didn't let that happen.
At the time of the first legislative election
after the Second Intifada...
Fatah, a party backed by
the PA and PLO...
that had negotiated with Israel,
was in power.
But many Palestinians saw Fatah
and its approach as ineffective.
Hamas, which was now
a political party
in addition to being a militant group...
won most of the seats in 2006.
People voted for Hamas as a way to...
to express their disapproval
of the ongoing status quo
which was that the peace process
had failed
and they had had two uprisings
and no state was in sight.
In response to an armed
militant party winning...
Israel banned laborers from
leaving Gaza for work.
Then, when militants captured
an Israeli soldier...
Israel carried out airstrikes in Gaza...
and tightened its control on the sea
limiting fishing capabilities
to only six miles.
Politically, within Gaza,
Hamas had won the election...
but the PA was still
the governing body...
with Fatah under its wing.
A conflict broke out between
Hamas and Fatah...
and Hamas seized power
of the entire strip in 2007.
This is when Israel put Gaza
under the official blockade
that continues today...
tightening Israel's grip
over Gaza even more...
trapping over 2 million Palestinians inside.
This time, Israel closed the main crossing
for commercial goods...
made travel even more restrictive...
banned exports from Gaza...
and imposed restrictions on
the import of essential items...
such as fuel, medicine, and food.
They even used mathematical formulas...
to determine the necessary caloric intake...
for people in Gaza to control
how much food they would allow in.
Basically, we live a slow death
in Gaza.
Even before major escalations.
People cannot travel freely.
We have Israeli drones...
hovering around 24/7.
There's always stress.
Over the next several years
reoccurring conflicts and airstrikes
made the already devastanting impacts
of this blockade worse.
Israeli airstrikes destroyed vital infrastructure...
such as water and power plants.
Repairs were delayed by the blockade...
which impacted the delivery
of construction materials.
And for each militant attack on Israelis...
Israel killed far more Palestinians
in retaliation.
At times, Israel would slightly lift restrictions...
but it was never close to matching
the humanitarian needs
of Palestinians in Gaza.
According to a UN report from 2022...
The 16 year blockade had made
78% of the water in Gaza undrinkable...
left 62% of Palestinians inside of Gaza
in need of food assistance...
living with rolling power cuts
that last on average
11 hours per day.
That is our normal life.
We would have 8 hours of electricity,
12 hours of electricity...
It changes depending on the situation
and the availability of fuel.
We are completely dependent on Israel.
This is what many Palestinians
and international law calls
collective punishment.
Collective punishment is when
cancer patients cannot travel...
because they get denied.
And collective punishment...
It means also that Palestinians
cannot have their own hospitals...
and they cannot treat...
their patients.
Collective punishment means
the people of Gaza now are punished...
for the most recent escalation.
When you look at the crime of genocide...
which is, you know, the
intentional destruction...
of a whole people in part or in whole.
We are seeing elements
of that crime
being committed and carried out
in the Gaza Strip...
right now.
There's equating...
between Hamas and all Palestinians.
And this is not the first time
that we're going to see people in Gaza
and civilians in Gaza,
half of whom are children...
pay the price for Hamas
or anything else.
Israeli and US leaders
have emphasized
that Israel has a right to defend itself...
by wiping out Hamas completely.
But the majority of casualties
in the Gaza Strip...
aren't Hamas fighters.
They're civilians.
It's an interesting question
to consider whether or not...
things would have been different
if Hamas didn't exist.
But the thing is, Hamas didn't exist
until the late 80s.
But the occupation of the Palestinian territories
has been since 1967.
And the original Palestinian displacement
was 1948.
And Hamas didn't really emerge until much later than that.
I think that anybody who follows
Israeli and Palestinian politics
with some level of honesty...
knew that if...
what happened
hadn't happened
something else was going to happen...
because the status quo
was unsustainable.
The world has to recognize this suffering.
Even before we have escalations.
The reason we have escalations
is because...
people cannot find any hope.
No one wanted to get to this point.
The tragedy of it all in my mind...
I think, besides the loss of human life...
is that it was preventable,
easily preventable.